earlier today I had the opportunity to
sit down with an amazing friend an
amazing colleague Benjamin Hall for his
first in-person interview since he
sustained horrific injuries while
covering the war in Ukraine one year ago
he has made inspiring and incredible
recovery and today we spoke about this
and much much more now he's sharing his
full story in this book you've got to
read this book there's so much in there
it's called saved it's available for
pre-order first print edition uh right
now amazon.com hannity.com and it will
be released on March 14th now originally
we planned to tape just long enough to
fill a segment on the show for tonight
we sat for over an hour
and the story was so riveting we're
going to run it in full tomorrow night
so please watch this interview he is a
hero he is a friend he is a colleague
and I learned a lot about courage and
heroism today from him
we slowed down an abandoned checkpoint
and I don't know where the first missile
came out of nowhere
mine's about 30 feet in front of us
immediately Pierre shouts reverse the
car reverse the car there were two
ukrainians driving as well and five of
us in the car
the car got stuck we couldn't go back
and Pierre shouted get out of the car
everyone get out of the car and the next
second the second bomb hits right in
front of the left of the car
and that one I went black
and I
I was in a dark place
I couldn't feel or see
um and I'd taken some shrapnel in the
eye and I the matchboxized shraple in my
in my neck and I was I was out I was out
dead
and then I saw my my daughter out of
nowhere into this Blackness right in
front of me came my daughter honor
and she said to me
Daddy
gotta get out of the car
real as if she was in front of me
I don't know where she came to me and I
came to and I opened up my eyes and my
instinct took me towards the car door
and I scrambled I pulled myself out and
I got out of the car and the third bomb
hit the car itself right after that
nice thing I know I wake up it's thrown
me away I'm on fire my right leg is gone
I roll around I try to put it then you
you had lost your foot of that I'd lost
the foot the foot had gone ironically I
didn't notice it at the time and then
your eye is injured and and everybody's
bleeding everywhere they took pieces out
of my skull out my left hand which has
been put back together with all torn up
the thumb hanging off
so um I was lying there
lying there and Pierre was still alive
at this point
and Pierre immediately said don't move
Russian drones Russian drones
and so I'm lying there and this Barren
landscape
trying not to move trying to think of
what we can do looking at my injuries
realizing how badly injured I am
and I get my cell phone out and no
reception can't get hold of hold of
anyone no one knew where we were we'd be
moving around a little bit
and so I actually had my cell phone out
and the first thought I was I will
record what I'm seeing and I actually
stopped and I took a picture of my leg
and some of my injuries and I
immediately thought well
my children can't see this if I don't
come home that can't be the last picture
that perhaps they see so I was sitting
there and I deleted them immediately
but we lay there for a while longer
and uh Pierre again who was lying about
five feet away from me or so
just lying there
said the Russians the Russians
and after a while a car came past it was
up on this hit a ridge just by me I
shout out a car car and I started trying
to wave at it way better trying to get
attention it didn't see me and Pierre
said it's the Russians it's the Russians
and I said uh it doesn't matter I'm so
badly injured I've got to go Benjamin
joins us tomorrow for the full hour hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else